This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's a subgenre of kid videos on YouTube that are named things like, my toddler masters the iPhone and baby works iPad perfectly. Hi, this is Bridger. Say hi, Bridger. Hi, Bridger. He is playing with the iPad and he just turned to.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯 (Roman Mars)。YouTube 上有一类儿童视频，名字五花八门，比如“我的幼儿玩转 iPhone”和“宝宝完美操作 iPad”。嗨，这是布里杰 (Bridger)。跟大家打个招呼，布里杰。嗨，布里杰。他在玩 iPad，他才两岁。
Some of these video titles also say things like, must see in all caps, but like all things that say must-see, it's not true. You can totally do without seeing these videos. Mostly it's a bunch of babies drooling and poking at iPhones. Thing is though, these tiny drooling iPhone pokers are actually able to execute commands, open up programs they want to use, play games, and take photos, and despite what we parents believe, it isn't because our kids are smart. You're so smart, Bridger?
其中一些视频的标题还会用全大写字母写着诸如“不看错过”之类的话，但就像所有标榜“不看错过”的事物一样，这并不是真的。不看这些视频完全可以。基本上就是一群婴儿流着口水，戳着 iPhone。但问题是，这些流着口水的微型 iPhone 戳客实际上能够执行指令、打开他们想用的程序、玩游戏、拍照，而且不管我们这些做父母的怎么认为，这并不是因为我们的孩子有多聪明。你太聪明了，布里杰？
Well, some of them might be smart. Bridger seems pretty smart. That's producer Luis Abec. But mostly, it's just that iPhones, actually computers in general, are just incredibly easy to use. Today's user interface in the modern computer is what I call Grunt and Point. It's very primitive communication, so that's why I call it Grunt. That's Christina Engelbart. Her father, Doug Engelbart, had a vastly different vision for what computers could be than these super
好吧，他们当中有些人可能确实很聪明。布里杰看起来挺聪明的。这是制作人路易斯·阿贝克 (Luis Abec)。但主要原因还是 iPhone，实际上包括计算机在内，都变得极其易于使用。现代计算机当中的用户界面，我称之为“吼叫与指向”。这是一种非常原始的交流方式，所以我叫它“吼叫”。这是克里斯蒂娜·恩格尔巴特 (Christina Engelbart)。她的父亲道格·恩格尔巴特 (Doug Engelbart) 对计算机未来的设想，与这些幼儿都能使用的超级
simple devices that toddlers can use. Doug Engelbart's vision required us to actually learn stuff. In order to really push the envelope of human effectiveness and intellectual effectiveness, you don't want to be confined to just a very small vocabulary of grants and clicks. So you want to actually have a full language. Doug Engelbart was a pioneer in his field, and his main goal wasn't to make computers that toddlers could use. He wanted them to be as powerful as possible. And imagine that if we took the time to learn how to use our devices,
简单的设备有着巨大的不同。道格·恩格尔巴特的设想需要我们真正去学习东西。为了真正突破人类效能和智力效能的极限，你不想局限于一小套由吼叫和点击组成的词汇。所以你实际上需要拥有完整的语言。道格·恩格尔巴特是他那个领域的先驱，他的主要目标不是制造连幼儿都能使用的计算机。他希望它们尽可能强大。想象一下，如果我们花时间学习如何使用我们的设备，
if we became fluent in their language, their potential to make us smarter, more efficient humans would be huge. Doug Engelbart, who passed away in 2013, grew up during the Great Depression on a small farm-stead near Portland, Oregon. He later served as a radar technician in the Navy during World War II.
如果我们精通了它们的语言，它们让我们变得更聪明、更高效的人类的潜力将是巨大的。道格·恩格尔巴特于 2013 年去世，他在大萧条时期在俄勒冈州波特兰附近的一个小农场长大。后来他在二战期间担任海军雷达技术员。
He was a West Coast optimist who studied at UC Berkeley and was influenced by the 1960s counterculture. When he later had his own lab, he made his researchers attend personal development seminars where they talked about feelings and life philosophies. In his time, Engelbart's ideas were lofty and unique and relentlessly idealistic. My father was considered a cook and he was not widely respected or even widely known. Engelbart's name may not be widely known, but if you work at a computer, you use one of his inventions every day.
他是加州大学伯克利分校的一名西海岸乐观主义者，深受 20世纪 60 年代反文化运动的影响。后来他拥有自己的实验室时，他让研究人员参加个人发展研讨会，探讨情感和生活哲学。在当时，恩格尔巴特的想法高远、独特且充满不妥协的理想主义。我父亲被认为是个怪人，他没有受到广泛尊敬，甚至不为人知。恩格尔巴特的名字可能不太广为人知，但如果你在电脑前工作，你每天都在使用他的发明之一。
I don't know why we call it a mouse. Sometimes I apologize. It started that way and we never did change it. one of his inventions every day. That's Engelbart showing off his revolutionary invention in 1968, the computer mouse. Engelbart's mouse had three buttons, though he would have added more if he'd been able to fit them. And it was meant to be used in conjunction with another device called a key set, which looked like a small 5K piano, one key for each finger, and was controlled by your left hand. This device over here is unique to us, and we always have to just define it, explain it.
我不知道我们为什么叫它鼠标。有时候我会道歉。事情就是这样开始的，我们从来没有改变过。他每天都在使用的一项发明。那是恩格尔巴特在 1968 年展示他的革命性发明——计算机鼠标。恩格尔巴特的鼠标有三个按钮，不过如果能装得下的话，他会加更多。它原本是与另一种叫做键盘组（key set）的设备结合使用的，那个设备看起来像一个小型五键钢琴，每个手指对应一个按键，由你的左手控制。我们这里的这个设备很独特，我们总是必须去定义它、解释它。
It provides for you the one handy equivalent of what you can do with a keyboard. The idea was that with your left hand on the key set and your right hand on the mouse, you could do almost everything that you would need to do without moving your hands back to the keyboard, including typing out characters of the alphabet and executing shortcut commands. But beyond the shortcut commands that we use now with a keyboard, Engelbart's mouse and key set opened up a larger vocabulary that we could use when communicating with a computer. So, we could do like my dad did,
它为你提供了你可以用键盘完成的操作的一种便捷等效方式。这个想法是，左手放在键盘组上，右手放在鼠标上，你几乎可以完成你需要做的一切，而无需将手移回键盘，包括键入英文字母和执行快捷指令。但除了我们现在用键盘使用的快捷指令之外，恩格尔巴特的鼠标和键盘组开启了一个更大的词汇库，供我们在与计算机交流时使用。所以，我们可以像我父亲那样做，
put your left hand here. I visited Christina Engelbart at the Doug Engelbart Institute, which is an educational and consulting institution that aims to promote his ideas. It's housed at Stanford Research Institute in Menlo Park, the very place where a father and his collaborator Bill English built the first prototypes of the mouse in 1964. Christina showed me the key set, and I
把你的左手放在这里。我拜访了位于道格·恩格尔巴特研究所的克里斯蒂娜·恩格尔巴特，这是一个旨在推广他理念的教育和咨询机构。它坐落在门洛帕克的斯坦福研究所，也就是 1964 年这位父亲和他的合作者比尔·英格利希 (Bill English) 制造出第一个鼠标原型的同一个地方。克里斯蒂娜向我展示了键盘组，我
tried to get a feel for what it would be like to type my name with it. OK. So there's 26 letters to get it feel for what it would be like to type my name with it Okay, so there's 26 letters to the alphabet and what's the first letter? Yeah, so what number would you use? I mean you can guess yeah Basically each finger on the key set is assigned a numerical value My thumb is assigned a one and my pointer a two so if I want a three I need to press down my thumb and pointer because they add up to 3.
试图体会一下用它打出我的名字会是什么感觉。好的。字母表里有 26 个字母，体会一下用它打出我的名字是什么感觉。好的，字母表里有 26 个字母，第一个字母是什么？是的，那么你会用什么数字？我的意思是你可以猜，是的。基本上，键盘组上的每个手指都被赋予了一个数值。我的大拇指被赋予一，食指被赋予二，所以如果我想要三，我需要按下我的大拇指和食指，因为它们相加等于三。
Then we map numbers to letters. So C would be my thumb and my pointer. Exactly. Yeah, you just... It is like playing the piano, like just the chords and the piano. Right, physically. It requires that one. With each letter mapped to a number, A being one, you can imagine that it gets harder once you reach the middle letters of the alphabet.
然后我们将数字映射到字母。所以 C 就是我的大拇指和食指。完全正确。是的，你只需要……这就像弹钢琴，就像弹奏和弦和钢琴一样。没错，从身体上来说。它需要那个。由于每个字母都映射到一个数字，A 是一，你可以想象，一旦你到了字母表中间的字母，这就变得更难了。
Yeah, I have no idea off the top of my head what number of the alphabet. Oh, is. Right. Well, there's a chart you can hang up next to your desk to reference what number each letter is. But the point is, all of this takes some practice. Still, I could imagine how with a lot of repetition, you could get fast at using the key set.
是的，我脑子里完全不知道字母表的哪个数字。哦，是。对的。嗯，你可以把一张图表挂在办公桌旁边，用来参考每个字母对应的数字。但重点是，所有这些都需要一些练习。不过，我可以想象，通过大量的重复，你确实可以熟练使用这个键盘组。
Doug Engelbart felt his mouse and key set would allow us to communicate with computers more fluidly and efficiently. Even though it sounds pretty hard to learn. It wasn't as if Engelbart was against these or family devices. But he just believed that if we were willing to put time into learning computers, they could do so much more for us. He felt they could help us communicate and collaborate to become better humans and more effective problem solvers.
道格·恩格尔巴特认为他的鼠标和键盘组能让我们与计算机进行更流畅、更高效的交流。尽管这听起来很难学。这并不是说恩格尔巴特反对这些家庭设备。他只是相信，如果我们愿意花时间学习计算机，它们就能为我们做更多的事情。他觉得它们可以帮助我们交流和合作，让我们成为更好的人类和更高效的问题解决者。
So that meant how can you make humans in groups and organizations, be dramatically more effective. How effective can you make them? Is there a limit? And maybe the idea that computers could help us collaborate doesn't sound that crazy now, but Engelbart was working at a time when most people thought of computers as giant calculators. Their purpose was to automate tasks. And in my father's paradigm, why would you ever automate how you do things now?
所以这意味着如何能让群体和组织中的人类效率大幅提高？你能让他们达到多高的效率？有没有极限？也许计算机可以帮助我们合作这个想法现在听起来并不那么疯狂，但恩格尔巴特工作的时代，大多数人把计算机视为巨大的计算器。它们的目的就是自动化任务。在我父亲的范式中，你为什么还要去自动化你现在做事的方式呢？
A computer affords a whole new way of working. What way would you work if you weren't limited to the old technology? In the early 60s, Engelbach got funding to start his own lab where he could experiment with all of his ideas. His lab hosted one of the three centers of the ARPANET, which is one of the key ancestors of the Internet. So Engelbart actually helped invent the Internet. And throughout the 60s and early 70s,
计算机提供了一种全新工作方式。如果你不受旧技术的限制，你会如何工作？在 60 年代初，恩格尔巴特获得了资金来创办自己的实验室，在那里他可以试验他的所有想法。他的实验室托管了 ARPANET（互联网的关键祖先之一）的三个中心之一。所以恩格尔巴特实际上帮助发明了互联网。在整个 60 年代和 70 年代初，
his group built entire online collaboration systems that included video conferencing and collaborative text editing. Here he is presenting those things and what became known as the Mother of All Demos. I need to know what terminal you're on, Bill. 13! Okay, I'd like to have him see my text. And so this special thing, if I label 13, will switch.
他的团队建立了几套在线协作系统，包括视频会议和协作文本编辑。这是他在演示这些东西，也就是后来被称为“所有演示之母”的演示。比尔，我需要知道你在哪个终端上。13！好的，我想让他看到我的文本。所以这个特殊的东西，如果我标记 13，就会切换。
Switch over, so on his display he sees my text, so I'll execute it. And sure enough it does. But what's that, running around? Well, if he's looking at my text, he'd like to have something to say about it. The reason people call it the Mother of All Demos is that in it, Inglebart showed the world so many revolutionary ideas, the mouse, of course, but also a bunch of things that didn't catch on until decades later. At the time, most people hadn't even heard of personal computing, let alone the internet. And here was Doug Engelbar demonstrating the ancestors of tools like Skype and screen sharing and Google Doc editing in the 1960s.
切换过去，所以在他的显示器上他能看到我的文本，所以我将执行它。果不其然，它做到了。但那是什么，在周围跑来跑去？嗯，如果他在看我的文本，他会想对它说点什么。人们称之为“所有演示之母”的原因在于，恩格尔巴特在其中向世界展示了如此多的革命性想法——当然有鼠标，还有一堆直到几十年后才流行起来的东西。当时，大多数人甚至没听说过个人计算，更不用说互联网了。而道格·恩格尔巴特在 20 世纪 60 年代就展示了 Skype、屏幕共享和 Google 文档编辑等工具的祖先。
Despite all of this by the early 1970s, Engelbar's lab ran out of funding to continue his research. Much like his three button mouse and key set, his other ideas were seen as interesting but complicated and not particularly marketable. And meanwhile, another computer visionary had entered the scene. One that, unlike Doug Engelbart, you've probably heard of, a guy by the name of Steve Jobs. Steve Jobs was never satisfied with the first or the second, or even the tenth pass at making something simple. That's Larry Tesla, who worked at Apple from 1980 to 1997 as VP and Chief Scientist.
尽管如此，到 20 世纪 70 年代初，恩格尔巴特的实验室资金耗尽，无法继续研究。就像他的三键鼠标和键盘组一样，他的其他想法被认为很有趣但很复杂，并没有什么市场价值。与此同时，另一位计算机远见者登场了。与道格·恩格尔巴特不同，你可能听说过他，一个名叫史蒂夫·乔布斯的人。史蒂夫·乔布斯对制作简单东西的第一版、第二版甚至第十版从未感到满意。这是拉里·泰斯勒 (Larry Tesla)，他在 1980 年至 1997 年期间担任苹果公司的副总裁兼首席科学家。
No matter how simple you made it, he would come and say, that's pretty good, but I think you can make it simpler than that. And then he would leave us like, well, how? Once in a while he would make a suggestion, but usually he just walked away and we had to figure out a way to make it simpler. One thing Jobs wanted to simplify was Engelbart's mouse and key set combo. Jobs had first seen the mouse and key set at Xerox Park, which was a cutting edge computing
无论你把它做得多简单，他都会走过来说：“这挺好，但我认为你可以把它做得更简单。”然后他就会留下一句“嗯，怎么做？”让我们自己琢磨。偶尔他会给出一个建议，但通常他只是走开，而我们必须想办法把它弄得更简单。乔布斯想要简化的其中一件事就是恩格尔巴特的鼠标和键盘组组合。乔布斯最初是在施乐帕克 (Xerox Park) 看到鼠标和键盘组的，那是当时一个尖端的计算机
research facility at the time. In the 1970s, when Englebart's labs started to disband, a lot of Englebart's researchers and some of his prototypes ended up at Xerox Park. Jobs found the mouse and key set intriguing but entirely too complicated to use. He dismissed the key set altogether. And in 1980, Apple's Larry Tesla wrote a memo to Apple employees saying that the mouse Apple was developing would only have one button. Throughout the years, Apple held on to its one button mouse, even as competitors developed two button mice.
研究设施。在 20 世纪 70 年代，当恩格尔巴特的实验室开始解散时，恩格尔巴特的许多研究人员和一些原型机最终来到了施乐帕克。乔布斯发现鼠标和键盘组很有趣，但使用起来实在太复杂了。他完全摒弃了键盘组。1980 年，苹果公司的拉里·泰斯勒给苹果员工写了一份备忘录，称苹果正在开发的鼠标将只有一个按钮。多年来，苹果一直坚持其单键鼠标，即使竞争对手开发了双键鼠标。
Steve was very attached to it. Apple never even considered including Inglebart's key set companion to the mouse. It was too costly, clunky, and complicated to learn. At Apple, we wanted people to come and do the bookstore, look at the software, try it out, figure it out in the first few minutes, and plunk down a credit card and take the computer home. And it wasn't okay to say, well, take it home, and work on it every day for several hours a day.
史蒂夫对它非常执着。苹果甚至从未考虑过将恩格尔巴特的键盘组作为鼠标的配套设备。它太昂贵、笨拙且学习起来太复杂。在苹果，我们希望人们走进来逛书店、看软件、试用、在最初的几分钟内弄明白，然后拍下一张信用卡，把电脑带回家。说“好吧，把它带回家，每天花好几个小时研究它”是不行的。
And in six months, you'll be really good at it. And suddenly, computers were for everyone, even Bridger. Hey, Bridger! You know, that's beautiful. That's a beautiful thing. And that it's helped a lot of people. That's Christina Engelbart again. The problem is when that's the whole mission.
六个月后，你就会非常擅长它了。突然之间，计算机适合所有人了，甚至连布里杰也行。嘿，布里杰！你知道，这很美好。这是一件美好的事情。它帮助了很多人。这是克里斯蒂娜·恩格尔巴特。问题是当这成为全部使命时。
Christina thinks that when we prioritize simple user friendly devices over more complex learnable ones, we limit ourselves and we might miss out on important ideas. And for a while at least, Steve Jobs did exactly that. When Jobs showed Engelbart the brand new Apple computer, Christina said that her dad responded like this. My dad said, well gee, what about communication to, you know, to the networking? In other words, document sharing, video chatting, and all the collaborative stuff that Inglebart was excited about. For Inglebart, collaboration was the most important thing.
克里斯蒂娜认为，当我们优先选择简单、用户友好的设备，而不是更复杂、可学习的设备时，我们就限制了自己，并且可能会错过重要的想法。至少有一段时间，史蒂夫·乔布斯正是这么做的。当乔布斯向恩格尔巴特展示全新的苹果电脑时，克里斯蒂娜说她的父亲做出了这样的反应：“我父亲说，‘哦，天哪，那网络连接呢？’”换句话说，文档共享、视频聊天以及恩格尔巴特热衷的所有协作内容。对恩格尔巴特来说，协作是最重要的。
Computers needed to connect. But for jobs, at this point anyway, simplicity was key. And Steve said, oh no, you don't need that. Everything you need should be on your desk. A personal computer is all you need. At the root of Apple's success lies the world's first personal computer. The Apple 2, small, inexpensive, simple to use. The first computer an individual could take out of the box, plug in, and run.
计算机需要连接。但对乔布斯来说，至少在当时，简单性是关键。史蒂夫说：“哦，不，你不需要那个。你需要的一切都应该在你的桌子上。一台个人电脑就是你所需要的全部。”苹果成功根基的背后是世界上第一台个人电脑。Apple 2，小巧、便宜、使用简单。个人可以开箱即用、插电并运行的第一台电脑。
Bringing computing down to a personal level. One person, one computer. That was taped from a 1983 promotional video for Apple. Here's Jobs himself, talking about missing the importance of networking. When it was first demonstrated to him at Zerix Park in 1979. At over 100 alto computers, all network using email, etc. etc. I didn't even see that. I was so blinded by the first thing they showed me, which was the graphical user interface. I thought it was the best thing I had ever seen in my life.
将计算带到个人层面。一个人，一台电脑。这段录音来自苹果公司 1983 年的一段宣传视频。这是乔布斯本人，谈到在 1979 年在施乐帕克首次向他演示时，他忽略了网络连接的重要性。当时有 100 多台 Alto 计算机，全部通过电子邮件等联网。我甚至没有看到这一点。我被他们向我展示的第一样东西——图形用户界面——彻底迷住了。我以为那是我一生中见过的最好的东西。
Of course, jobs eventually came around to networking, but I take Christina Engelbart's point. As a designer, being married to simplicity could be limited, and we might also be limited by simplicity as users. The example my dad used to like to give, and I think this is really appropriate, is the difference between a tricycle and a bicycle. So anybody can get on a tricycle, especially if you see somebody else ride it, you know, you can
当然，乔布斯最终还是接受了网络连接，但我认同克里斯蒂娜·恩格尔巴特的观点。作为一名设计师，执着于简单性可能会受到限制，而作为用户，我们也可能受到简单性的限制。我父亲喜欢举的例子，我认为这非常贴切，那就是三轮车和自行车之间的区别。所以任何人都可以骑上三轮车，特别是如果你看到别人骑它，你知道，你可以
just get on and ride it. You don't need any special training. You just kind of do it and figure it out. But that's fine if you're just going to go around the block a couple of times or something. If you're trying to go up a hill, a tricycle is a pretty bad way to go. You want a bike with gears, and you learn how to balance and steer it and change gears because it gives you a lot more power. You can cover a lot more steep ground. A lot of people have made the point that by dumbing down computers so much that it's easy for anybody to learn, we've made it so that
直接坐上去骑。你不需要任何特殊的培训。你只要骑上去自己摸索就行了。但如果你只是绕着街区转几圈什么的，那没问题。如果你想上山，三轮车是一种非常糟糕的交通工具。你需要一辆带齿轮的自行车，你学习如何保持平衡、转向和换挡，因为它能给你带来更大的动力。你可以征服更陡峭的地形。许多人指出，通过把计算机做得太傻瓜式、让任何人都能轻松上手，我们导致了
most people don't go to the trouble of learning something that could give them more leverage, more power with their computer. And I think that's a fair criticism. That's Larry Tesla again. He agrees that early on Steve Jobs overlooked networking, but he also thinks that Jobs was right to push for simplicity. If you make it as we did at Apple, so that just about anybody can do things that they do every day on a computer or on a smartphone, then you're giving them the only opportunity that they'll probably ever have to
大多数人不会费心去学习能为他们提供更多杠杆、更多计算机掌控力的东西。我认为这是一个公平的批评。这是拉里·泰斯勒。他同意乔布斯早期忽视了网络，但他也认为乔布斯坚持简单性是正确的。如果你像我们在苹果公司那样做，让几乎任何人都能在电脑或智能手机上完成日常事情，那么你就是在给他们提供他们可能永远拥有的唯一机会，
benefit from that power. Doug Engelbart might look at the world now and say they're all on tricycles. They should be on bicycles. The thing is our tricycles have gotten pretty awesome. They become so powerful and so well designed that we're actually able to get around without ever learning how to balance onto wheels or shift gears.
去从中受益于那种力量。道格·恩格尔巴特现在看着这个世界可能会说，他们都骑着三轮车。他们应该骑自行车。问题是我们的三轮车已经变得非常棒了。它们变得如此强大且设计精良，以至于我们实际上不需要学习如何在两个轮子上保持平衡或换挡，就能四处走动。
Maybe that's the world we're living in today. One where a lot of Inglebarps ideas have come to fruition and almost anyone can access them, including you, and your mom and your granddad. And yes, pretty soon, you're drooling iPhone poking toddler. But I think Christina would say there's still more we could learn, and our simple interfaces have sort of hidden that path from us.
也许这就是我们今天生活的世界。在这个世界里，恩格尔巴特的许多想法已经结出硕果，几乎任何人都可以使用它们，包括你、你妈妈、你爷爷。是的，很快还有你那个流着口水戳 iPhone 的幼儿。但我认为克里斯蒂娜会说，我们还有更多东西可以学习，而我们简单的界面在某种程度上向我们隐藏了这条道路。
They've hung a curtain over the complicated stuff to keep us from having to face it. And in doing so, they keep us stranded in grunt and point land. My dad always said, well sure, easy to learn, easy to use is fine for the beginner. But once you've used something for a year or two or five, why would you sit down and use the computer the same way you did the very first day? You came in, that's ridiculous. You need to have a clear, streamlined path for advancing into a much more sophisticated, holistic way of interacting with the computer.
它们在复杂的东西挂起了一道帘子，让我们不必去面对它。这样做，就把我们困在了“吼叫与指向”的世界里。我父亲总是说：“好吧，易学易用对初学者来说很好。但一旦你使用了一两年或五年，你为什么还要像第一天来到这里时那样坐在电脑前使用它呢？这太荒谬了。你需要有一条清晰、简化的路径，通往更复杂、更全面的计算机交互方式。”
Maybe the question is, what kind of users do we want to be? The best design may not always be the one that's user-friendly at first sight. It might be the one that allows us a degree of virtuosity if we think investing the time is worth it. Or in other words, it's the one that helps us switch from tricycle writing to bicycle writing. So that if we want to, we can go up some really big hills. 99% invisible was produced this week by Luisa Beck with Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan, Avery
也许问题在于，我们想成为什么样的用户？最好的设计可能并不总是第一眼看上去就用户友好的设计。它可能是允许我们在认为值得投入时间时达到一定精通程度的设计。或者换句话说，它是能帮助我们从骑三轮车转向骑自行车的那个设计。这样，如果我们愿意，我们可以爬上一些非常巨大的山。本周的 99% Invisible 由路易斯·阿贝克 (Luisa Beck)、凯蒂·明格 (Katie Mingle)、萨姆·格林斯潘 (Sam Greenspan)、埃弗里·
Trouffleman, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSign, an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful, downtown Oakland, California. We consulted a ton of people who were very generous with their time for this episode, so special thanks to Mark Weber, the computer history museum, theory Bardini, Bjorn Hartman, Eugene Eric Kim, Joe Blalock, James Yarchenko, Glenn Fleischman, Harvey Lateman, Martin Hardy, Carolyn Rose, Laura Olberg, Wesley Willett, Fred Turner, and Brian Crabtree for their help researching this story.
特鲁夫曼 (Avery Trouffleman) 和我罗曼·马斯共同制作。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的一家建筑和室内设计公司 ArcSign 的办公室里制作。我们在这一集里咨询了很多人，他们非常慷慨地付出了时间，因此特别感谢马克·韦伯 (Mark Weber)、计算机历史博物馆、西奥·巴迪尼 (Theory Bardini)、比约恩·哈特曼 (Bjorn Hartman)、尤金·埃里克·金 (Eugene Eric Kim)、乔·布拉洛克 (Joe Blalock)、詹姆斯·亚琴科 (James Yarchenko)、格伦·弗莱施曼 (Glenn Fleischman)、哈维·拉特曼 (Harvey Lateman)、马丁·哈迪 (Martin Hardy)、卡罗琳·罗斯 (Carolyn Rose)、劳拉·奥尔伯格 (Laura Olberg)、韦斯利·威利特 (Wesley Willett)、弗雷德·特纳 (Fred Turner) 和布赖恩·克拉布特里 (Brian Crabtree) 对我们研究这个故事提供的帮助。
Wesley Willett, Fred Turner, and Brian Crabtree for their help researching this story. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Marts. If you follow me at one of those two places, you'll be aware of all the talks and events that we have coming up. We have a cool Tumblr, and our Spotify playlist will make you feel like you're living inside of a 99PI episode. But I encourage you to explore the entire world of 99% invisible at 99pion.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
韦斯利·威利特 (Wesley Willett)、弗雷德·特纳 (Fred Turner) 和布赖恩·克拉布特里 (Brian Crabtree) 对我们研究这个故事提供的帮助。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并点赞。我在 Twitter 上发推文 @RomanMarts。如果你在其中一个地方关注我，你就会知道我们即将举行的所有演讲和活动。我们有一个很酷的 Tumblr，我们的 Spotify 播放列表会让你觉得你生活在 99PI 的一集节目中。但我鼓励你在 99pion.org 上探索 99% Invisible 的整个世界。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。